there was a new york times article just
came out
about the crime surge that we're dealing
with right now all throughout american
cities crime is going through the roof
and then here they just can't understand
why it doesn't make you know they
the left last year defunded the police
tried to abolish the police in some
cases let criminals off the hook for
their crimes let a lot of criminals out
of jail and said that they wouldn't
enforce the law and now crime is going
up it's a real head scratcher i can't hm
what what maybe it's something about the
virus i don't know maybe it's maybe
that's a symptom of covid as people get
more violent so the new york times can't
make sense of this
the closest they get is they say quote
the fallout from the 2020 racial justice
protests and riots could have
contributed to the murder spike
police officers scared of being caught
in the next viral video
may have pulled back
on proactive
anti-violence practices
is anyone out there maybe if you're
writing in the comments could could
anyone translate that into english for
me
they the police
may have
pulled back
on proactive
anti-violence
policies
is
i guess every word there is english but
when you put it all together that
doesn't seem to make a coherent
sentence it's just a bunch of
pretentious jargon and mealy-mouthed
language trying to
avoid something
i guess oh they're trying to avoid the
obvious which is if you want crime to go
down i'll simplify this as best i can
want crime down
arrest criminals
crime go down
criminals go prison is that is that
simple enough for the new york times i
don't know if they can get it through
their heads you know about helix i've
talked about helix for years they make
these great beds well now helix is
moving beyond just mattresses
they are starting to make sofas and
they've just launched a new company
called all form they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door so what makes an
all-form sofa really cool well for
starters it's the easiest way you can
customize a sofa using premium materials
at a fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric and it's
spill stain scratch resistant really
great fabric you pick the sofa color the
color of the legs the sofa size the
shape you make sure that it is perfect
for you and your home
tailored exactly to your tastes they've
got arm chairs and love seats all the
way up to an eight seat sectional so
there's something for everyone and you
can always start small and buy more
seats later on
all form sofas are also delivered
directly to your door they've got simple
quick assembly no tools needed if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds a little risky you do not
need to worry you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep it that's more than
three months and if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for free and give you
a full refund they also have a forever
warranty literally forever and all form
is offering 20 off all orders for our
listeners at
allform.com to find your perfect sofa
check out allform.com
knowles the new york times can't figure
out why crime is going up after we
defunded the police and let all the
criminals off the hook so they've got
they're they're onto something though
they've got a lead here's their lead
they say
these three factors could have played
into each other
the pandemic might have driven more
people to violence you know the pandemic
you know that virus when someone says oh
my body's aching
i got this cough
i really want to just rob a nike store
oh yeah i just
oh gosh with all oh these aches and
pains and i lost my sense of smell and
taste
let me go uh stick up a family on the
street yeah that
i just i don't know i'm just i feel
impelled to do that so they say it's the
pandemic could have done it the police
might have been able to prevent at least
some of the violence if they had
remained proactive or had worked better
with the public
so if the police had just done their
jobs
like we wouldn't let them do
then we probably wouldn't be in this
mess right now
well you got you're the ones new york
times and liberals you're the ones who
said the police shouldn't do their jobs
but now you're blaming them for not
doing their jobs you wouldn't let them
do their jobs well they have an answer
you see that that's in the last part of
the sentence they say or if they'd
worked better with the public so if the
police
hadn't
forced us
to force them to stop doing their jobs
then they could have done their jobs at
all better it's their fault police if
you just hadn't made me so angry if you
hadn't made me so angry then we wouldn't
be in this position
uh-huh seems a little a little unfair
seems
i don't think that reason
and argument quite works and then
finally they say without so many guns
what violence did occur could have ended
up less deadly that's the gun's fault
it's the guns it's the virus's fault
it's the cops fault
it's the inanimate object's fault
what's the only group that the new york
times is not blaming for the surge in
crime
it's um
hold on
oh the criminals it's the criminal it's
not the criminals bear no responsibility
and the leftist politicians who let all
the criminals off the hook and out of
jail they bear no responsibility
it's
the cops
and the inanimate objects
and a coronavirus
from china
i don't know listen i'm not
i'm not one of these geniuses who works
at the very fancy new york times i
do not have advanced degrees in
criminology
or anything like that
but it seems simple enough to me the new
york times actually has gotten into this
trouble before it was fox butterfield
their reporter who would have headlines
decades ago he'd have headlines in the
new york times that would say things
like
the crime rate uh
the crime rate continues to fall
despite prisons filling
despite
as though as though this would be
unexpected that when you throw criminals
in jail the crime rate goes down as
though maybe
there's no way that these things could
have anything to do with one another hey
you
thanks for thanks for being here i'm
glad to see you i always like seeing you
when you come around these parts
unfortunately sometimes our our pals
here or in the big tech world don't want
to give you notifications
about these new videos so to maximize
your chance of getting the notifications
ring that bell subscribe also if you
want to get the unvarnished uncensored
too hot for big tech
version of the show head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe for free
and leave a five star review we'll see
you then
[Music]
[Music]
you